Ron White's comedy salute to the Troops  starring ron white we're gonna have a  party it's called Operation hangover  with special guest Kathleen Madigan I  spent two weeks in Afghanistan we got a  hundred and fifty Humvees here but  nobody could pick up a porta potty and  Lewis Black they put a helmet on me they  put a flak jacket on they they handed me  a right and I fell right over  and musical guests Margo Rey John Oates  and Rascal Flatts  Ron White's comedy salud to the Troops  with Tim Wilson Robert Hopkins dick  Henley and Alex Reymundo we have a  little french bulldog named pearl and  the other day my wife said I finally  figured it out that dog he's jealous of  me that dog loves you so much he can't  stand it if I'm in the same way with you  and I said I'll don't be ridiculous she  walked into the kitchen and pearl jump  on my stomach and said I can have all  your babies at the same time what she's  coming back I like nothing's going on  nothing is going on  you